barkley hello to you mr bartlett it's
good to talk to you so much to talk to
you about
good morning good morning uh let's talk
about the test and trace to start with
should we um
we've got an exclusive here on sky news
today about a floor in the app that
means that people
can't access the 500 pound grand are you
aware of it and how are you going to fix
it
i wasn't aware of that specific issue it
would be led by
the department of health if that's the
case uh but you're right to point to the
fact that we have put in place
uh support for people to self-isolate
the 500 pounds
as well as for those who break the rules
a
fine to help encourage the right
behavior but it's part of a much wider
package of support
working with local authorities to
enhance our test
and tracing regime and and so it's not
just one aspect
that we're focused on it's a package of
support and in fact many of the
conversations we've been having
uh in recent days with local leaders has
been councils has been about how we work
with them
to deliver better test and trace and
we've been allocating funding
to support them in doing so okay but
just
let me go back to the um the app and the
fact that you don't know about our story
it's it's on our website but let me just
tell you it's a hidden flaw
in the process for claiming the payment
and it means that uh people that
are tested positive can only claim the
support if they are given a code
by a human contact tracer i mean it's
hardly
worth breaking world beating is that
really
well i think the number of people that
have downloaded the app
is extremely high i've been using it
myself i think it's very
easy to use when you go into uh for
example uh
uh premises it's very easy to scan so i
think actually
it's been very effective but the point
is
the point is it is one of a range of
things we're doing including
local schemes with local leaders we've
been funding that in terms of the
enhancements
for compliance uh for communication for
enforcement
uh and it sits within our overall
commitment to uh track and trace over 12
billion pounds
of funding which we've allocated uh but
it is one of a number of things we're
doing it's not one
to be judged in isolation criticized by
labor and also by
a poverty charity um are you going to
look at it
well the uh well the key is that the the
funding is there if there's a specific
issue obviously
uh health colleagues will pick that up
but the key is that funding is available
and what the chancellor announced
yesterday was a further strengthening of
the support for businesses
by international comparison extremely uh
positive
funding in terms of the extension of the
self-employed
income support grant uh the support for
individuals in terms of those coming
back into work
where they're able to work at one day
but still get up to 95 percent
of their income when you interact uh to
february with the the furlough bonus
as well as the job support scheme so so
it's a comprehensive you said
in terms of the amount of funding we're
allocated a comprehensive
package of support as we get people out
of the furlough process
into coming back into work okay this
latest economic plan
uh announced by your colleague rishi
sunak yesterday basically an admission
that andy burnham
was completely right and that greater
manchester was not getting the support
that it needed or deserved
and no because the the plan the
chancellor announced is for
the first of november onwards in terms
of the job support scheme
manchester as with all parts of the
united kingdom has been benefiting from
the furlough scheme that runs
to the end of october it's been
benefiting from the self-employed income
support scheme
and the second transfer which takes
payments up to just under 15 000
pounds it benefits from the local
authority funding
the 3.7 billion pounds that we've
allocated nationally a further 1 billion
pounds
of additional own ring fence local
authority support it benefits from its
share
of specific schemes such as our
infection control 1.1 billion pounds of
funding
through the adult social care system and
it benefits for example in its schools
through the 1 billion pounds of catch-up
funding
that has been allocated so so the point
is there is a range of measures as part
of our balanced approach
tackling the virus but also protecting
jobs
and we have a range of national schemes
the issue with the mayor
of manchester greater manchester was
unlike other mayors such as
the mayor of the liverpool city region
or leaders in lancashire
or the mayor of south yorkshire who
worked very constructively
with the government the mayor of greater
manchester wanted a special deal he
expressly wanted something better
than what was available for people in
liverpool and we want to take a national
approach
and treat all areas in a consistent
manner he actually wanted to do better
for his
constituents goodness me the very idea
um let's see if you can answer this for
me third day in a row
um can um gyms in greater manchester
open
or not i've been speaking to your
colleagues over the last two days they
can't tell me what's your understanding
well it varies on gyms in different
areas lancashire for example had a
different approach
uh to liverpool manchester is going into
tier three measures uh well has over
midnight
uh tonight for any of your listeners uh
wanting to know for their part of the
country what the rules are
on good.uk they can just put in their
postcode that will tell them and it will
vary from area to area
around the country but the key is where
businesses are forced to close
because of the restriction measures we
have put in place
financial support for them not just in
terms of the job support scheme
where the government will then pick up
two thirds of their wage
but also the additional support for
businesses in terms of their rent so up
to 3 000 pounds
of business support so it's about saying
where it varies from area to
area but where support where
restrictions are required
in order to tackle the virus what we
have done is put the support package in
place
for those businesses both for the
individuals working them that are
affected but also for the businesses
faced with pressure for example on their
rent
so they're able to meet those people
okay so can jim's open in manchester
uh i don't know uh for jim specifically
uh in manchester what i would do is i
would go to the postcode
checker dot uk and that's where that
would be addressed
yeah you are wrong about liverpool and
lancashire jim's are open in both of
those
is my understanding okay gyms were open
in lancashire but as part of the tier
three measures we put in place in
liverpool they were not
in response to requests from leaders in
liverpool
we have then changed that
that gyms can open as a result of the
changes in liverpool
they weren't initially as part of the
tier three and the point of the question
is
the point of the question is it points
to the fact that as we work with
directors
of health in different parts of the
country the needs of different parts of
the country
okay that is why we're taking targeted
so you know what's happening in
liverpool we don't know what's happening
in manchester let me ask you what's
happening let me ask you if i'm about
what's happening with russian sooner
can i ask you about rishi of course you
can but the point is
thank you here we go he met yesterday
with his colleagues
inside a pizza restaurant to make the
announcement
um you're not allowed to do that are you
not allowed to mix with work colleagues
inside in a tier 2.
business meetings are allowed in
restaurant venues so
so yes they are and the point let me
sorry if i can just make the point
yesterday the day before actually i had
uh
the uh housing secretary on the program
he said it was a loophole
that shouldn't be in place and it was
going to be tightened two days later
you're flighting it
well the point is you are allowed to
meet with restaurants under the guidance
for for work
meetings uh and what the chancellor is
doing was consistent
uh with that but the wider point the
point i think most of your viewers
will want to know is where their
businesses are affected where their jobs
are affected will there be financial
support for them
and what the chancellor set out
yesterday was for businesses who as a
result
of restrictions are closed they will get
the additional support such as the three
thousand pound business grants
per month but what came out of
discussions with business leaders
is that many businesses that weren't
required to close
were still impacted by the restrictions
as part of our tackling of the virus and
therefore we brought forward further
measures for those businesses
up to two thousand one hundred pounds a
month in grants
and a strengthening of the job support
scheme so that workers in those
businesses
who are not able to function as they
would normally where they're facing
uh less trade as a result of the
restrictions
what we don't know is whether we can
have a working lunch uh
inside or not your colleague told me two
days ago that it was a loophole that it
was going to be closed yesterday it was
flighted by the chancellor
what are people who are working in
hospitality supposed to think
well you just asked me that question
i've just answered it that it is allowed
for for working
uh lunches but the the wider point and i
think the points
feel that you clarify the situation
which is why i pressed you further on it
but thank you for clarifying it there's
a lot to talk about
uh talk to me if you would please about
this test and trace advert that for the
department of health
a senior delivery manager for test and
trace operations
they'll be paid up to 2 000 pounds a day
experience of turning around failing
call centers a must
goodness me that's not a ringing
endorsement is it well what we've done
with the
the test and traces go from an extremely
low base so just a couple of
thousand tests a day up to a capacity
now of 380 000 a target by
the end of this month of 500 000 a day
that is a massive scaling gap
that has been delivered by the
department of health uh if we were not
funding that k
you would be the first uh to challenge
me we've allocated over 12 billion
pounds so there's no shortage of funding
to do this
but it is a huge logistical challenge
it's a big delivery
uh change to go from such a low base to
delivering
on a mass scale there's new technology
coming on stream that will help us
deliver
more testing and quicker testing because
it's not just the number
of tests it's the speed of test that is
also hugely important
and we've got new testing uh technology
coming on stream to help us with that
but we have allocated their funding in
order to do this
because it is a priority and we've
scaled it up massively
over recent months two more quick
questions i know you're uh
rushed for time this morning do come in
and see us next time if you can it's
always great to have ministers
in the studio um two thousand pounds a
day but it's going to cost
looking at the figures 20 million quid
to feed
kids uh hungry kids over the half turn
break
um 500 million pounds uh to eat out
to help out 20 million quid to feed kids
over the half term break who otherwise
will go hungry
come on well we are targeting funding so
we put a billion pounds for example to
uh schools for catch up 350 million
pounds is ring fence specifically
for disadvantaged children we put an
additional 9 billion pounds
into welfare support to support families
in terms of pressure on their household
bills
one of the best ways of supporting
families is by helping people to keep
their jobs that's why
we've had the comprehensive package of
business support such as the furlough
scheme the grants the tax deferrals the
loans
to help them do so we put additional
funding into local authorities who often
work at the sharp end
with many of the the the families who
are experiencing hardship for example
help
with things like council tax bills so
there's a whole range of measure the the
the point of substances is absolutely
right uh k that we are helping
children that is the right issue to
focus on the question is what is the
best way
of doing so is that best done through
the welfare system and the support that
we're doing by helping people keep their
jobs
by supporting local authorities by
targeting school funding
as i say with a billion pounds on catch
up so we have
we changed things when the schools were
closed now the schools are open we've
gone back to
the approach we had before but alongside
that we put a comprehensive
package of additional support to help
exactly
yeah 20 million quid is an easy win
isn't it to put food in kids bellies 20
million pounds given all the other money
that's sloshing around why don't you
just do it
well because it's not then you would say
that's just for for a short period of
time
indeed so so it wouldn't be for a week
and the point is it's not the summer
money that you're talking about
it's the fact that what is the best way
of delivering support we think the nine
billion pounds
that we put into the welfare system the
billion pounds we put in
to schools for catch-up the additional
one billion pounds we've just allocated
to local authorities that is not
being fenced that builds on the earlier
3.7 billion pounds
we think those are better ways of
getting support to families
and as i say actually the best way of
supporting families
is by helping as many people retain
their jobs
and that's why we've had uh the sport on
furlough the supporters self-employed
and so forth so you're quite right it's
not about the 20 million it is about
what is the best way to support families
in need and we've taken over 200 billion
pounds k
that we have spent supporting the
british public so it's not about 20
million
it's about the 200 billion pounds that
we've allocated
or 2 000 pounds a day for somebody to
fix a failing call center
let me ask you briefly before i let you
go with your brexit hat on there seems
to be a landing zone
on state aid fishery is now the major
sticking point
are we going to get a deal well i hope
so i think
as i've always said k it's in both sides
interest to have a deal
that is what we've always been committed
to but that deal needs to reflect that
we're
leaving the eu we will regain control
of our fisheries it was a key issue for
many
of your viewers uh during the brexit
debate and it is important
that the deal reflects that but it's in
both sides interest uh to come to a deal
and i hope that is very much
what we secure okay um i must let you go
it's always difficult to do a down the
line interview isn't it it sounds as i'm
interrupting you i'm just trying to have
the discussion do come in and see us as
i said next time it'd be great to see
you enjoy the rest of your day thank you